I don't know what to say
I'm struggling I've never seen anything
quite as shoddy as I've experienced
today and I I'm wondering why this place
is still open how much money we make
tonight how much money did you make
about 1,500 bucks 1,500 how much money
do you make tonight a couple hundred
couple of hundreds but with all the
noise complaints Johanna had to come
free rooms isn't it right absolutely
you do make a profit but your mother
loses money it does not make sense
nobody says we were sensible people oh
we just bless people having a million
dollars in debt is not blessed first of
all you don't understand what you're
talking about you're talking business
your business mate where's the partner
I'm not a businessman and I'm not trying
to teach you people would be the
business people it's this is our home no
one knows the difference between a hotel
in the home and does anyone else know
how much stress and press you're under
you know I do what I have to do to keep
the doors open you know and we just quit
talking about money Richard why can't it
be financially secure so that we are
financially we're sure we are not you
can laugh at this and laugh at that and
we just wanna make every happy man they
say it ain't an issue with me you're
refusing to look at the issue because
you and your sons are taking advantage
of Joanna no it's not an issue so why
are you talking so much [ __ ] it's
not [ __ ] this is everything you say
to me I'm just ignored
I'm gonna knock him on his ass but you
think I care what you think about me
Richard don't you go have your cigarette
I'm glad my cigarette me relax a little
bit yeah and we'll come back and discuss
this
I'm not going to argue with your father
I'm just going to call it as I see it
this Lodge needs to be run by our
business and when I listen to your mum
stressing out about payments and you two
going off running your own little
businesses because you two are butting
heads it's a [ __ ] disgrace this [ __ ]
has to stop because right now this
lady's suffering yet your heads are so
far in the [ __ ] sand that no one can
actually see the damage you're causing
my worst nightmare is that Duke and
dusty never can get on the right page
and and I'm stuck till I'm 90 years old
trying to run this place then then I die
and it's gone I'm not a miracle worker
if you want this place to survive you
need to come together as a family and
run this place as a proper family
business it is way past everybody's
bedtime I've seen the morning good nice
[Music]
this place is insane I mean I've never
seen such a badly run lodge in all my
life and the one person I feel sorry for
his Johanna everybody else they think is
a big joke I'll tell you what I'm not
[ __ ] laughing
[Music]
with all the partying going on this
Lodge I hardly got a wink of sleep this
Lodge is in a dreadful state and I think
everyone's blind to it that has to
change
yeah there's something I want you to
understand because I think the only one
who can actually appreciate some things
that's been going on here yeah yeah we
got with me what he might be showing me
next I don't know how much worse it
could get I think it so much for coming
this is Joanna she is the owner and
these are esteemed guests that have been
staying in your Lodge I need to hear the
truth and so does Joanna let's start off
with you madam please I mean my
boyfriend stayed here a few days ago
both of us were really pleased we were
all the way in the Myrtle suite so we
were the closest to the bar and we could
hear like we were next to it my
apologies I'm sorry please madam sir we
got the honeymoon suite in the bathroom
wasn't clean so we you know I cleaned it
and it just kind of grossed us out the
fact you had to clean the room before we
tried to relax this is saying madam
please we got into bed and I felt
something I pulled it up with my foot
and it was a pair of underwear dirty
underwear oh my god
yes I am mortified that is completely
unacceptable did you have any
interactions with Richard Richard
invited us to the back room what in the
light of Baja
to do what there was marijuana in the
back
he offered which we did not partake
taking guests into the butt room and
offer them marijuana it's not a hippie
commune it's a it's a lodge I know